so you know uh we'll put up we'll put a
pin in that and then for for the people
who watch
this show and know me they've probably
heard this but just to you know for
those for you guys who haven't heard it
when my experience my first experience
with critical race theory
intersectionality during occupy was if i
agreed with them
they would they would recognize my mixed
heritage if i disagree with them they
would accuse me of being a wealthy white
male
clearly none of that was true but it was
just if you disagree with us
you're a white man and then i'm like
well my mom is actually and i'm from the
south side i'm poor and they're like oh
i'm so sorry
oh you know so just depending on none of
your ideas changed it's just like now
they've reframed
they they i was told explicitly that i
you know needed to reconsider my
opinions as a white man and then when i
explained actually i'm a high school
dropout from the south side of chicago
and from a mixed race family
then all of a sudden these white
liberals went oh
oh now i see what you're saying like
legit also now i was like oh i'm like
the most disrespectful and insane thing
i ever experienced i was like what are
you
what what is this like do you have an
actual author well it's reductive and
that's the dehumanizing part is it's
reductive for the person who's on the
receiving end of that you know to
literally be told you cannot speak on
this topic because you are
xyz like you just don't even get a seat
at the table but then it's i think it's
dehumanizing for the person who is
holding the view and so
equally equally like i'm concerned about
um the people who are being treated this
way and you know having their
their lives ruined because they're being
canceled or whatever they're they're
going to lose their job they're going to
be smeared and you know in
all the newspapers and their and their
you know reputation is in shambles at
the end of it
um and i'm concerned for them but i'm
also concerned for the people who have
bought into it because it's
it's really a dangerous way to look at
other human beings
so after you start noticing this this is
critical gender theory stuff popping up
yeah you mentioned that they realized it
wasn't working
so they changed their tactic or whatever
well just like so so walk us through
what's what's the next thing that
happens
well actually i really appreciate how
you defined terms for us at the
beginning and read that definition of
critical theory that's super helpful
um and that's kind of the next tack we
took was like okay it seems like we're
talking two different languages
like we're saying no we're we're doing
justice like that's why we started this
organization
it's about justice it's about you know
disparities in mental health care that
you know most of the world that needs
mental health care doesn't have the
resources they need that's why this
organization exists
um and you're telling us that we're not
doing justice so i think we need to
define some terms you know so we really
started there
um i can't remember which the first one
was that i did but i just started
cranking out organizational position
papers that essentially defined terms
um and and we we at that point we had
entered into like a formal
um series of i don't know better word
for it than struggle sessions
it was these all org meetings with the
board chair president sometimes a third
party mediator present
trying to just even figure out like what
what is needed where is the harm you
know because there's all these
accusations of this organization is
causing harm there is harm
but it was always in that kind of
passive voice you know like it wasn't
ever like you harmed me when you said
this
there is harm there is harm um and so
we were like okay first thing we need to
define is psychological safety what does
it mean because that that term is being
thrown around you know like
psychological safety has been violated
um i can't even trust you know i can't
have a conversation with you
with your ideas or whatever the things
you've said it's like okay
fine let's look up what psychological
safety actually is
and define it and we defined it based on
the calling of the american mind i don't
know if you're familiar with that book
jonathan jonathan hyatt and greg
lucanoff and um
so they really go into like the
psychology behind what's sort of
happening on university campuses
right now and now has you know like
overflowed into the whole
culture um and so i used a lot of the
material from that book
and then amy edmondson is a professor at
harvard business school who coined the
term psychological safety and i used a
lot of her research
and then i used some trauma-informed
models of psychological safety which is
you know we do trauma work so
very much all in alignment with each
other so you've got this like business
school perspective you've got these guys
who wrote this book about the phenomenon
of college campuses and you've got
um these trauma-informed groups that
basically teach about how to be safe
when you're working with trauma
survivors it's like a whole other level
of safety right
um and essentially what we saw is
while these people were trying where
they were trying to be helpful
to people who have been hurt you know
it's like yes there's racism yes there
is
you know discrimination against people
with different identities totally agree
but what you're doing when you say like
you like you said this
if you don't speak you know this thing
into the space this person is going to
be erased it's like you're essentially
saying that person has no agency
they're the biggest wimp on the planet
that if people don't like validate them
at every moment and affirm them and clap
for them and
and do whatever they say they're going
to fall apart and dissolve
have you seen the dsa meetings the viral
videos
no so this is the democratic socialists
of america
these are a series of viral videos where
if i i wasn't there i can't tell you
what the whole
several hours looked like but in a span
of a few minutes every time someone
spoke they offended someone
and so oh this is the old video i've
seen this yeah a couple years
ago point of personal privilege and the
one guy says guys
please the chattering is giving me
anxiety right someone goes don't say
guys exactly sorry yeah so that's an
extreme version of what i mean
right but it's what happens when you
take all of those people and put them in
the same room together
well yes it's yeah exactly when it when
your sense of self is dependent on
others validating you and other
others accommodating you i think
narcissism is a great word for
entitlement is another great word for it
and it's counterintuitive because it's
like yeah if a person's been hurt a lot
there is a sense of like we need to take
care and we don't want to
you know make them feel unsafe but also
it's like counterintuitive in that
this person probably actually needs to
be pushed out of their comfort zone
you know so so you're having these
company struggle sessions
i mean it doesn't sound to me like that
like these people actually wanted to
help anyone it sounded like they just
wanted to have power and bully
i wouldn't characterize in that way they
did they're like the they're
definitely geared towards helping people
but again it's the strategies versus
values
like they they really because i think i
mean you have to applaud them for
living in integrity with the moral
framework that they've adopted like they
they truly believe like this is
how social justice is done and so
they're carrying it out according to
that
that conception of reality that marxian
framework that you just read about
where it says this constant like so
somebody's in power
and the person who's marginalized or
disenfranchised they have no say in the
conversation so all the norms are just
established by discourse there's nothing
nothing actually objective
see that's that's the real shift is it's
not these
these social categories of race
and biological sex and gender identity
and all these things those are really
weapons towards what is actually under
assault which is objective truth
which is why this whole moral panic
you know that took place over the last
whatever period of time
are um i kind of think of it as an
epistemological panic it's like it
really
it really disoriented people in terms of
how they know
how they can know whether something is
helpful and true and just
and then and then their methods of
getting to how they know what they know
also we're under salt because science
itself is under assault
as a way to know if you if if you know
you understand their view that there is
you know it's all about power dynamics
you know the
the the ideology the underlying moral
framework held by critical theorists
and the expanding umbrella is there is
no truth but power that's that's a core
function of their belief it's it was one
of the core tenets of
fascists right so they're not ultra
nationalists but they hold that
authoritarian worldview which is why
it may be true that there are
individuals who think they're helping by
doing it yes
but certainly it is these are
organizations and these
are uh you know corporations that are
exploiting it for wealth
yeah absolutely i think there are
different you know
varying degrees to which people
understand what they're involved with
right i think there are certainly people
who understand that this is a tool that
can be used to
radically transform our system of
government and consolidate power
and then like i said they're like the
foot soldiers who are just doing what
they're supposed to do within their
moral framework who
really think that they're helping people
they really see this as like
oh my goodness it's the critical
consciousness right that's the word
that's used that that's where the word
woke comes from is that your
consciousness has finally been awakened
to the reality of power and oppression
these structures of power and oppression
that are everywhere and you just didn't
see them before
so there it's like their mandate now i
mean it's this conversion language right
it's like i was blind but now i see
and so it's like it's so i see this
thing now and these
these poor white straight cishet
whatever people
they don't see how they're pressing and
so if i if i care about the people who
are being oppressed i have to help them
understand
how they're part of the oppression just
like when i hear from
christians who say i don't want you to
go to hell so i have to tell you
what to teach you exactly it's like if
that's my moral framework i don't love
you
if i'm like i think you're going to hell
but i don't care good luck
you know you know some issues i'm having
with it is as you said ebermex kennedy
said that denying
racism or kennedy kennedy candy candy
candy candy
uh that one of the ten aspects of racism
is denying racism but questioning
something
is not denying something that's very
important to understand
and also questioning critical theory
for people to have an issue with that
seems counterintuitive because the whole
point of critical theory is to question
power structure it is so it should be
questioned that's why i i don't
say you know i hear you'll hear from
people like christopher ruffo it's
critical race theory
well that completely excludes critical
gender theory and that
just excludes everything which is
underneath the umbrella of critical
voice
he is focusing specifically on critical
race theory
right that that's his mission so yes but
the the
terms are really sloppy like you'll hear
people refer broadly to critical race
theory when they mean critical theory
um and that's part of the problem but
it's like i think that's just the
the nature of when a social philosophy
or
a critical theory makes it into the
mainstream and it really just becomes
more about the phraseology the more than
the philosophy so people know the jargon
and they know what you're supposed to do
and what you're supposed to support and
what you're not supposed to support
they don't know the philosophy behind it
i think it's another big mistake
because i've seen that i'm seeing the it
is a it is a huge
failure of the anti-woke to embrace
critical theory as their target because
now what we see
are the the woke left saying okay name a
critical theorist
and give me the idea that you have a
problem with and then what happens is
they pull up specific quotes from like
ben shapiro where he'll read one quote
and say well
actually actually i agree with that one
the issue is that
critical theory isn't as a whole the
real problem we're experiencing what
we're experiencing is the fascistic
ideology there is no truth but power
which in many ways is rooted in critical
theorists in frankfort school etc
but it's it's it's well beyond any
particular
identity group race or or gender it is
just a group of people
who will claim harm in any way and
exploit the system in any way and right
now they've found an attack vector
we as a society don't like racism we
don't like bigotry
we don't like discrimination they attack
that
by saying you're being racist when you
try and then ask them what that means
they'll give you a different definition
each time
because it's not critical race theory it
is just an authoritarian
authoritarian fascistic tactic towards
gaining power
yeah and it's incoherent and it's a
double standard but they are
acting according to the theory which
says
everything is socially constructed so
you can continue to reinterpret it's
reinterpretations of reinterpretations
of reinterpretations because there's
nothing ultimately real it's
post-modernism it's post-modern
it's post-modern philosophy put into
like a management theory
for how to keep people in line it seems
to me like
it's it's what happens when you have no
moral framework i suppose there is one
there is no truthful power
i think one of the things i've often
talked about is the difference between
the two factions in the culture war
there's a lot of different definitions
you'll get people will say libertarian
verse authoritarian globalist versus
nationalist lepers right whatever
i think one uh core separation may be
judeo-christian moral framework versus
absence of moral framework just power
dynamics
and so uh the example i give is bill
maher for instance often talks about how
you don't need religion to be moral
however he believes in many classically
liberal principles which are
founded in judeo-christian moral
framework for instance
the example i often give you know ad
nauseam to the audience who knows this
already is
the fifth amendment a right to a speedy
trial innocent until proven guilty the
right to
remain silent the core of uh innocent
until proven guilty
is blackstone's formulation which was
inspired by the story of sodom and
gomorrah literally out of the bible so
you take away these moral frameworks
bill maher who was raised in a
judeo-christian society who understood
these things but without the religion
doesn't understand how that framework
changes how that how that you know forms
society
and what that means in terms of justice
you now have an entirely new
purely secular religion or whatever you
want to call it non-theistic religion
with no core moral framework other than
the writings of critical theory
and a bunch of other i mean there's
other non-critical theorists who are
included in their
in their citations often and the ideas
they have is
just get power by any means necessary
period yeah and i think it's a great
point
talking about the framework that's being
replaced because i've also heard
as you know everyone's trying to figure
out what do we do about this woke
movement what do we do
um is just sort of like just get rid of
it i'm like that's not enough
you you need you need a positive moral
vision
to replace the moral vision that has
become embraced by many people because i
i do agree that it has religious
connotations it's a way of of
understanding yourself in relationship
to the world and then acting out of what
you believe
in a morally into integrated way and
that that's the definition of religion
and so it's like okay so you can just
say let's just get rid of of all these
you know
critical social justice people and the
woke movement and that
that'll be good like no because there's
clearly like a hunger here for something
power power yes but belonging yeah
and having having a moral purpose that
you can attach
to clear aims so like that kind of
teleological argument that is like
there's something that we're aiming for
that society is aiming for that each
human being is made for
um and so all of that is is is providing
people with meaning and you see like
very religious kind of activity coming
out of this you know ritual
and confession and conversion kind of i
mean so it's like you can't just
replace that with nothing thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time